[Music]
they accused trump of homicide
while joe's nonsense leads us horrified
once respected journalists turned
opinionated blow hard carl bernstein was
a complete mess during the trump years
every day was worse than you know what
what we are watching in the trump
presidency
is worse than watergate i keep getting
asked are there echoes of watergate in
this and
there are we're also witnessing
something we did not see in watergate
which is a meltdown by a
president who is demonstrably unhinged
what we're seeing
is worse than watergate but this may be
hard to believe
he's gotten even worse with trump out of
office
he is america's our own
american war criminal uh of a kind we've
never
experienced before trump's crimes as
a war an american war criminal in his
own country
that he has perpetrated upon our people
including the tens of thousands
of people who died because of his
homicidal negligence
in the pandemic putting his own
electoral interests above the health
of our people as they were slaughtered
in this pandemic
all right well i guess the only way for
a president to
not be called a war criminal is to not
start any wars by carl's theory
but that's because it's just not about
trump it's about you as columnist
aisha sultan tweeted now we have to
confront how many of our fellow citizens
support a war criminal
so now we're back to confronting people
cher can't help herself either
these days her biggest hits are on
social media over the weekend she
tweeted in part gop no they can't win
the democratic way so they'll do it by
white dominance
instead of ideas they have hate and
trump will kill america
kill america if we don't win in 22. so
the only way to beat the republicans is
to vote in the election you say they
won't let you vote in
doesn't she know trump has left the
building just like her brain
speaking of joe biden uh while trump is
killing us
uh elise biden's incoherence will give
us something to snicker about
on our deathbeds
[Music]
what must be what i don't know what that
was
let's hear that again a few more times
must be a reconciliation what must be
what
what must be what what must be what
i finally i all right i figured it out
cat he was mimicking the rhythm of the
question ike was trying to figure out
what he was saying but he was doing that
she was going and everything and he was
he was i think he was imitating her
right i don't know i really don't know
i have no idea what he said uh and i
nobody cares so that's fine yeah people
still want to talk about trump
i with that carl bernstein clip the
funniest thing by the way is
that he began by saying we need to quote
calmly step back
which is really interesting to say that
i'm going to call someone a war criminal
just like shares tweet where she's
making a pretty serious you know
allegation it has
four emojis in it yes it doesn't match
emojis soften the blow i think sandra
um what did you make of that sound bite
the bite and sound bad yes
i did my homework and i listened to it
over and i watched in the lips
they do kind of match the words so i
i don't know i don't do not claim but i
love that you captioned it anyway
what do people think he said his butt
spin i can't
unhear about that now like now that i've
seen it i i can't
unhear it yeah it's like that remember
that thing uh yellow or gold what was
that yanny and laura
danny and laurel remember that thank you
also the blue dress and the gold and
white dress
yes yep so you're welcome it's a very
divided country
but i prefer to be divided over this
right
i mean i wish i knew what the other
option was yes
i think his new gripe and we caught this
in his he was talking to the iraqi prime
minister today i think his new gripe is
when he gets questions
that aren't about pertaining to the
topic of the moment or the topic du jour
which is
laughable when you consider the
questions that donald trump got when he
was in office after delivering a speech
on the economy it was about
nothing about the economy um so that's
one to take in
do you worry that maybe biden is losing
a step faster than we thought or do you
think that's just
there's no obviously people do question
is cognitive abilities we have no
evidence or proof that
there are some moments that you really
do watch and you do
ask yourself is he okay it's it's like
computer glitches tyrus like little
skips in the
no i it's bro code for help get me out
oh my god help get me out like he's he
knows the
progresses are coming for him and every
chance he gets to speak with
loud help get me out like because he
knows it's coming there's nice
everywhere like kamala's just like this
how are you doing this morning
so poor guy
man damn it when you got to use code and
you're the president you know it's bad
in that office
but the whole this whole thing about
division and everybody's at each other
and what are we going to do and what's
the other
alternative and you have people like
great
thespians like cher jumping in and
telling you that
you're all going to die i used to like
it when republicans did the
fear-mongering because they actually had
a real villain if you don't vote for us
osama bin laden's going to come get you
and they'd be like oh and then it'd be
like in missouri going that might be
true he could come to the midwest
now it doesn't even they don't even have
the the energy
to give us the villain america's gonna
die and by the way remember watergate
because i did it maybe like every time i
you asked me a question i was like you
know i broke uh hard knock south bench
press record
uh the magic number 605. no matter what
the question is i bring the one great
moment i had in my life
constantly no matter what question you
asked him so what's your thought on uh
you know
hurricanes and stuff well they're worse
than watergate and by watergate
you know i did break that story like he
just can't let go of his one-hit wonder
he's like a he's like an artist
like every time i want to blame it on
the rain 605 pounds
yeah wow that's a lot of weight it's
like twice what i bench
wow born in 88 you benched 302 and a
half pounds
six foot three you're six foot three yes
yeah
it's amazing like a perfect dating
profile yeah and you know what it's like
people on tv they can't notice right
with this one
yeah or is it left i i don't know i
don't know i haven't been on grinder in
ages
up next there hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else